thank you
good morning our afternoon or whatever
welcome aboard guys it's Monday it's uh
it's a revenge of the sis we're here
live on Rumble and um you know
a lot of good things do anything fun
this weekend
yeah you know hung out clearly not sleep
Saturday
couldn't uh that was a little that was
very exciting very exciting this wild
black pilled geek twenty dollars a week
on pure dopamine at that point it was so
much fun blackfield geek twenty dollars
hello RTC thank you for your programs
Mercer is doing a big favorite of
normies which teaches them Maga and the
so-called left are the same with
different names thank you for that
you're welcome we got some new Dilly
stuff by the way guys just a quick
little little we have we haven't covered
Dilly in a while oh we got deleted it
but Dilly's getting a little too you
know are we gonna get to check out the
Dilly meme team have you heard about
this yeah about this one box the Dilly
meme team I've heard about it they're
making memes bro like uh you know
they're putting like putting like Trump
and like Loomer on the Avengers and
stuff you know real hot hot memes me
more special operations [__] [__]
some real Benny Johnson Vibe going on I
don't like it can we all admit though
this is going to be a fun election cycle
because we're so black filled now it's
gonna be so much fun covering them so so
real quick um hope you all lose previous
semper reloaded if there's a legal way
to physically snatch food out of Royce's
mouth I would do it
hey do not attack him that is a physical
threat and you will go to prison for
life forever yes people badly but bad
legal takes would have loved in the
comment section I'll have you know Royce
is a man-child so that's man pedophilia
it is that's right you know a pedophile
wants to steal baby food is that what
you want [__] pedophile I made a
stealing candy from a baby joke yeah
okay how dare you a bit that [__] Mr
Burns did yes correct and I was called a
pedophile okay
um I'm numerous death threats yes I saw
those
um very much so oh my god dude just a
shitload of yeah call me a pedo say that
I saying that I broke the law that I
used that I committed assault by simply
saying you were uh you you came out
lucky though because I'm pretty sure Mr
Burns was shot by a baby for his
transgression it's a good point he's not
shot by his baby the gun fell out and he
shot himself spoiler alert man I just
since season six on the DVD for that box
set [__] all right now I know who it is
I guess Royce is Maddie stalls and
mailed in his guess for that that
contest remember it was like that
Butterfinger contest yeah I thought it
was yeah everyone thought it was some
others it would have made a lot more
sense remember they made late in front
of that later in the sentence like Oh I
thought it was Smithers yeah that would
have made a lot more sense I love about
supper where they were
so mer said uh so that the Soviet I
couldn't of course couldn't see it
because Soviet block me a long time ago
because I called him a cringe Lord and a
thief he posted a picture holding his
giant weird-looking looking baby okay I
have kids it was [__] weird looking
that was weird I just did I he look
here's the thing my rage is always
untethered and no snow bounce did that
too
um but it's it's the crashing of a
Thousand Waves no but it's like it
wasn't like I saw the baby and was like
[__] that bit it's pasobiac like every
time
yeah every time I see his dumb face I'm
mad and I want to make a joke so yeah I
just tweeted a picture with his baby I
retweeted it I was very careful in the
wording yes because I said if there was
a legal way to physically say snatch
food out of this baby's mouth I would do
it and you would have thought that I
threatened to assassinate his baby
because he retweet quote quote tweeted
it was like what a fact don't you dare
come near my kids oh shut up up no one's
scared of you for so bad and then
nobody's scared and then a bunch of fake
Mega [__] episodes fake Mega Boomers all
lit up my reply saying they're gonna
shoot me they're gonna kill me listen
you sat through two years of coveted
lockdowns while they groomed and
molested your children and you're not
even gonna go to the mattresses for the
j6 people so don't talk tough with me
the only thing you care about is keeping
your [__] Social Security intact and
you [__] diabetes medication low
that's it that's all you care about
you're not you're not coming for me
sorry I can't hear you over your reverse
mortgage yeah seriously
I can't hear you over the engine of your
RV running because you sold your [__]
home that your parents left you I wish
your RV was running inside your garage
with you in it
um
so
Scarface made the front page boys yeah
that's that's next thing listen so
here's the thing this is Emmanuel
Rodriguez the actor who plays Royce
office and this is Ken Fresno here
how great is Rumble it's like the best
so here's the thing we CEO Chris from
Rumble great guy great guy great great
guy
um we uh we were a little angry on
Friday and yeah yes and we let it show
and then the Soviet [__] happened and
there might have also been some Twitter
Friendly Fire
you know science happens look
Virgie let us handle it all right we got
this so anyway
um we we had a lot of stuff we had a lot
of questions we had a we had a big rant
on Friday's show
um and uh subsequent tweets by Marsh
and I I get a message
we get a message I shouldn't say I the
the Show Twitter gets a message merch
and I both have access obviously to the
main show thing Marsh was out so
obviously I saw it and I of course we we
got it popped up and was like you know
it was one of those push notifications
right this also came he messaged us as I
was waking up from a horrible hangover
yeah after fighting with Soviet fans all
day so Royce just sends me like a
screenshot of oh yeah we're good we got
a DM you might want to check it out and
I see who it is and I'm like ah Jesus
Christ so obviously you think well there
goes the neighborhood
um Chris pavlovski who is honestly great
guy no but he he messages me and and you
know I'm not gonna I'll just give a
quick run down because I'm gonna get
when I'm gonna just [__] throw DMS up
but here's basically it saying that he
understood uh that you listened to a
clip of ours
where we were very upset and so much
money to know which clip
it was Friday's episode that was
Friday's episode I
think so many I think it was the hour I
think it was pretty I think he listened
to the whole thing man it was a man it
was a master class and passive
aggression and then at the end
aggressive aggressive yeah then straight
aggression so
um we were a little hot under the collar
because you know it's it's been there's
been things so building we explained our
frustrations being feeling like we're
pushed out being feel like we don't want
this to be a new we've been clear what
new YouTube where it's the same thing
and it really started feeling that way
and and it was really hard to get
answers you know uh answers like deeper
answers like you know algorithmic
answers I guess why are we why are we
well we're [__] two fat failed
podcasters and we're doing the best we
can in our 40s there's your answers
um hey also failed comedian okay fair
enough a failed actor I mean come on I
failed it a lot of stuff I want my
credit fair enough
you're a big failure there's your credit
best failure anyway
so we complained about it and it got
pushed and apparently now now I I this
message I got like a nine o'clock 9 30
Saturday night
and you know I've tried then I ran down
through all our list of grievances it
was a lot and then it was so much that
he just goes can you just call me I'm
like yeah I'll just call you because it
was a lot it was one of those where like
it's just easier if I explain
so I I'm out at this is the best this is
crazy
I'm at I'm at I I'm not doing karaoke at
one of the bars near here
and I already put my song in right and
then I'm like I guess I'll call him and
I go I'll be right back I walk outside
I I call him and he's in I I want to say
California working on something and and
he he listened to everything we had to
say
he made it clear that he didn't want us
to delete anything delete any tweet
which by the way that to me was one to
me was one of the I didn't expect it
but he was like no don't delete any
tweets you keep everything up there I
don't want it too late because Royce was
like yeah he's like I'll talk to Marsh
about this he's like no no leave him up
but I'm like too late I already took
some shits down well my my point is that
he never he never actually is the point
yeah he was like he was very cool with
that um he explained to us kind of
better how the live algorithm well I'm
going to call it algorithm but the live
system works in the podcast how the
shows pop up
um what's going on and then the other
grievances of course that we that we had
which we mentioned on Friday
um but we're cool now yeah we're we're
cool now and he handled us better than
anyone probably should have correct
that's fair that's actually fair so we
appreciate that that's fair uh and sorry
sorry for the um you know
unpleasantness
yeah because when I was when I talked to
him let me go let me loot Merchant
because at first he goes oh that's the
guy that ripped me apart right I'm like
yeah that's like I go yeah that's the
guy
yeah that's the guy who lit my living
room rug on phone yeah that's the guy
that's the guy that's the guy that's the
guy so I will say this and I mean this
you got back up sincerely
shout out to rumble for number one
making making it right which you don't
expect number two [__] having the CEO
reach out to somebody who is on their
platform you never [__] see that and
number three being really as transparent
as they can be as far as the way it
works and and basically admitting stuff
they're working on and you know all that
so close shots in the chat my bad boss
sorry about that skip so we'll be so
we're gonna be doing some stuff over out
at the well hey Rumble we're gonna be
doing some stuff some things we're gonna
actually we're gonna be doing some stuff
over at the rumble Studios very soon
we'll let you guys know what's going on
with that but shout out to Chris and
shout out to rumble because you know we
don't want to be like the New York Times
when they put something front page and
then the retractions like
page 45b like oh no we [__] up yeah so
but you know they also started reaching
out to us so it kind of worked you know
what we did we did you know we didn't
read it hey we we had some I have some
points that I still believe we were
right on it all worked out but that
being said
thank you for listening so if you're a
new Creator and you're [__] [__]
really pissed like we are yeah they
won't listen to you and Ann said Marsha
still working on his verbal restraint
look my [__] 40th birthday is like 26
days from now who's counting I don't
know if it's going to get much better or
probably going to get worse and Mercy's
like one of those women that has a
birthday month not just it's my birthday
every woman like that oh I'm doing it be
nice to me it's my birthday Mom we're
doing the whole month the whole month
and we're all doing what I want to do
every weekend for a whole month but I
don't want to go to Montreal for your
bachelorette my drinks for a month what
including my weeknight drinks oh wow all
the drinks all the drinks no but look
it's like I'm one of those where I don't
know if I'm gonna learn new tricks there
bud it's uh it's you know how you see
these guys slipping into dementia they
just get worse right so like I'm just
gonna get like aggressively more like
mean and racing oh it's a shout out
shout out when I'm I'm sorry I apologize
you see like you see guys like Biden and
like they're like super pedo guys so now
they just like we're president so then I
didn't know I didn't vote for him
um but I did a shower with his daughter
frankly I don't think most of the people
that did none that are alive um but you
know when they slip into dementia it's
like that's a very good point
the big like the old Meadows start going
to men didn't go like let me smell your
hair hey bring your kid over here I want
her fingers but no like you can't just
and they're like I don't know there's no
more filter anymore so I think it's my
cognitive uh abilities decline now it's
just I'm gonna get meaner on Twitter I'm
gonna say even meaner things about
people's dumb babies just don't shout
out to the new Photoshop Jack with
Soviet with a black baby that's pretty
[__] up it was the because they said
why are you overreacting to dark humor
and the guy goes this is not dark humor
and he's like do you want me to make it
darker and it was just like a big
uh it's been a fun weekend so look
here's making moves thank you uh again
Rumble for listening and by the way
special shout out to all the people that
kept tagging Rumble and Signal boosting
this the people that were doing it
genuinely because they cared about the
show and the people that were doing
because they [__] hate us and thought
Rumble was going to take us down I swear
to God and this is the truth if you guys
did not push that hard yeah we wouldn't
have got the sit down interview uh or
sit down meeting which more stuff are
coming but just to go just to say thank
you because that really helped so much
appreciated seriously yeah another
instance of people who hate us and
Signal boosting our [__] to a point
where uh we get enough attention yeah
just so you know I'm not saying that to
be like oh not being being serious uh
Scarface five dollars made the front
page boys oh yeah
please make your Twitter account to be
able to subscribe to either uh there was
seriously thing merch and I both applied
to have that Twitter blue where you
could subscribe we're still like pending
I'm pending you're still pending right
I'm still pending I've been pending for
like months I also lost my check mark
while we were in Austin oh that's
because you changed your drunkenly
changed it'll come back no I know but
it's like yes I don't know but it takes
not done it takes forever but you'll get
it back uh Mayo Riot uh merge it was
quite entertaining black Candace Owens
Niles Niles that can disowns folks
uh I I uh let me see the Jews against
DeSantis yeah that was and you're like
gee I wonder who was behind that one
[Laughter]
right like it's like so a bunch of
shrill Jewish women came in screaming
about the Santas and I'm going oh
whoever would have a group of friends
like this they could send a critical
thought what up [__] never say sorry uh
a critical thought check your DMs about
that thing that we were going to work on
on day wave not DMS check your email
uh Chuck Norris Gun Club five dollars
now with extra racism oh wow nice
topping uh so by the way we're not gonna
sit here and hide and because we want to
tell one more thing this is how this
this how it was explained to me
it now maybe please correct me if I'm
wrong for the people asking how does it
work like when you look at the live Tab
and because Rosen was asking us this too
so we do have an answer for some stuff
because let's give the answers out now
because we can it's all this too so
here's how it works when the front page
um the the top shows those are editor's
picks those are hand-picked shows right
uh obviously that's just the way that's
going to work but the other sub-genres
like the live Tab and the podcast tab
entertainment
every 15 minutes or so whoever's live it
pulls six shows and shuffles them at the
top
and every 15 minutes it should change
now sometimes you don't see a change
because of the cash and all that gets
caught but that is how it works and the
reason they do that which just makes
sense is so not only shows that I have a
bunch of user in the front other shows
get a chance for people to find them
which is
bear and that's sometimes like when if
from what you'll notice if you're a show
that's broadcasting in a in a like
entertainment for example like when
pestic goes live in entertainment he'll
be at the top of it because there's not
a lot of people broadcasting under that
tag so that block will be like that but
like right now if you do a podcast
there's probably 100 shows that are live
right now so you might not ever pop up
there you might but that's how it works
it's just random